on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
tonight on piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle top results down on gcse
results day the question is it time to
re-examine how we grade success claims
of bullying harassment and drunkenness
and the red arrows does britain's
military have a bullying problem and the
cash-strapped family who might just have
to kick out the ukrainian refugee plus
the new partying prime minister
[Music]
finland's pm faces fresh calls to quit
tonight the question is is she being
treated unfairly
[Music]
so
good evening my friends and a big big
welcome to piers morgan uncensored i'm
jeremy kyle so tomorrow is the day we
have all been dreading energy price is
set to go up again later tonight saying
we should put a new cap on the energy
bosses i personally think they should
wear whatever they like but i'm more
worried about the price and yet it does
feel like there's a light at the end of
the tunnel right now sadly for all of us
it's a train
good experts today warned it's getting
so bad we need coveted style bailouts
from the government rishi sunak says
it's a hard act to furlough
brilliant at number 10 is on board
though they say we should eat and out
and turn the lights out good we do have
good news tonight my friends on the
crisis of raw sewage flowing onto
britain's beaches this makes me so happy
it's upsetting the french
thank you mep's in fro apparently they
want to sue britain over the waste
leaking into the channel claiming it's
harming marine life apparently the
outflow of effluent hasn't deterred
migrants though who continue to arrive
in record numbers but at least the uk
sent its first unwanted visitor to
rwanda this week sadly it was prince
harry it does thank you he even he loved
uh it does feel like just about
everything's going up at the moment
doesn't it exaggerations in this country
have increased a billion percent
you're building your part up uh there's
one exception though spare a thought for
the school kids this gets serious top
grades in gcse results fell by three
percentage points this year results have
also exposed massive regional
disparities across this country now one
person and i'm so proud to say this you
did remarkably well as my daughter ava
she has suffered from severe dyslexia
from from the moment she went to school
and five years ago myself and her and
her brothers and sisters wouldn't have
even imagined that this young lady could
have sat exams and i have to tell you
without any shame i burst into tears
this morning at eight o'clock this girl
got eight gcses and she's going on to
study a level and i'm so so so proud of
her but that got me thinking that's a
great place to start the show tonight a
momentous day for thousands of teenagers
yes planning their futures after that
long ordeal but for many a very
difficult day who won't get what they
need and are concerned about what is
next so the big question tonight is is
the exam system itself now out of date
joining us is the chairman of the
campaign for real education chris
mcgovern and the education editor of the
sunday times sean griffiths welcome both
thank you very much indeed you've got
through my opening monologue um
let's start with you sean if we can um
i did o levels then they became gcses
i'm interested um tony blair raised this
and said that examinations at this point
a's gcses are not preparing our children
correctly for later life what's your
view of this
i i think he's right about gcses i think
they don't prepare children well for
later life we know that employers are
saying that they want children who can
work in teams they can problem solve
they can come up with new ideas they can
communicate and we have a very
old-fashioned system i think in gcses
it's turning out kids who memorize lots
of information um
it's a lot of rote learning a lot of
cramming for exams but it's not really
turning out kids who are equipped for
the 21st century what would you say to
the argument and i'll bring chris in
just a case what would you say to the to
the people who like me who think that
it's all well and good to do exams or
coursework or a combination of both what
about practical education what about
teaching kids how to fill out a passport
form or apply for a bank statement or
understand how you go about i don't know
signing for whatever why are we not
having a more practical education system
i think that's a really good question
and i think one of the things that's
really really wrong with the gcse system
is that
and people don't really know this
statistic but one in three kids at gcse
failed maths and english gcse those
fundamental qualifications you know
which are very practical maths and
english about writing about being able
to do maths
able to do something and if you haven't
got those basic qualifications you can't
go on at all so we have a forgotten
third of children and that that time
system is failing i agree and the thing
is chris chris mcgovern campaign for
real education i highlighted in the
introduction my daughter over if she
hadn't got maths and english today which
was a remarkable achievement i repeat it
and repeat it all night
would she have been on the scrap peep i
understand that you want to go back to o
levels and all that but for me
um that leaves a lot of people with a
very uncertain future should it not be a
combination yeah it should be a balance
shouldn't that um you say go back to o
levels but actually if you go to
singapore they still do levels and
interesting singapore about three years
ahead of us explain to me the difference
in layman's terms between gcse and o
level well the o level was a grammar
school exam it was more academic gcse is
a more knowledge light but tony blair is
saying there's too much knowledge in
gcse make it even lighter look tony
blair's ideas about communication
schools collaboration skills creativity
they're all very important but they can
be taught through traditional subjects
knowledge is really important you can't
think critically unless you have some
knowledge more practical knowledge
though more common sense less of you
know and latin whatever do you not think
we should be teaching our kids how to
open a bank account fill out their their
passport form do you not think that
absolutely we should and they don't in
school hang on a moment schools actually
are doing slightly better job in your
suggestion there they do do some of that
what i would suggest is that we should
be perhaps doing gcses at the age of 14
then would only be one year behind the
asia pacific and then they should
perhaps be going on vocational courses
or academic courses well here's the
thing universities of course they have
gap uh years my daughter's about to go
to edinburgh university bless and do
sports psychology and we'll get that gap
year which is of course part of the deal
but is also to to prepare you for the
outside world is there an argument to
say that at 15 and 16 going out and
doing an apprentice type thing or work
experience or something in the workplace
gets you more prepared for for the
outside world i think that's a really
good idea and there are some schools
that are starting to do this so there's
a school called xp and it sends pupils
out on kind of real world expeditions
into workplaces to solve real problems
and work in teams with employees to
really understand and learn about the
workplace there's a school that asks
kids to come to to school in suits to
kind of prepare them for the workplace
so i think schools are starting to
change but i think the problem with the
gcse system it's so kind of fixed and
it's like 10 subjects and it's two years
it is it is but but there is flexibility
you know i know this remember to go to
the foundation course and there are
certain courses you can do differently i
want to go back to how we make our kids
chris
smarter more more adaptable more ready
for for life is it
right a full set of exams 10 exams
fantastic is it exams that have more
coursework i mean the argument about
including coursework can be you know
what if the teacher doesn't like you or
doesn't get on with you or and here's
the big you know elephant in the room
all schools we know are interested in
how they look and how many people they
pass so if a large percentage and this
is a relevant point i know you'll agree
with if a large percentage is course
work are they not going to mark the
coursework higher because they want
their school to do well well we've seen
that in the last couple of years we've
seen teachers predicting grey's been
very very generous understandably so
we do definitely need more practical
skills in school but what we need to
also look at crucially everything
depends on the quality of the teachers
not many of our viewers tonight will
understand that in schools the majority
of staff are not teachers which is
extraordinary is that one of the major
failings of the education well it is
because what we have is that
we've got in a primary school for
example we have tables in most schools
with children sitting around with their
backs to the teacher at half the time
they have classroom assistance
that's expensive go to china where they
have class that's twice the size all the
children are facing the front and the
teacher is actually teaching those
children and they reach they're about
three years ahead by the by the time
they're 15. are we are we in danger then
from what you're saying it's interesting
watching your reaction are we in danger
of of making it too open too general and
too scattered and the old you know
teaching kids doing english maths and
all those sorts of things are we missing
out are we sending our kids into the
wider world uh less prepared
if you're going to build a house you
need to have foundations yeah primary
schools are important when i was as a
head teacher spoke to incoming parents
the first thing i said the most
important year in the child's life is
their first year in school right even
earlier than that of course the least
important when they're 18. you have to
get the foundations in right well and in
these private schools they teach the
basics they teach the foundations of
english and mathematics and science we
have to do that with all kids but by the
time they get to 14 as they do in in
asia pacific and parts of europe they
can go into more vocational courses
we've got to get away from the snobbery
academic versus versus vocational
they're equally important yeah and john
i think that's the point it's balanced
isn't it yeah it is and to be fair to
the tony blair institute think tank
report is saying that did he think all
of this when he was going education
education education or has he suddenly
become very vocal now he's no longer
thought of in high regard by many people
he's pretty vocal at the moment about it
but one of the things he's saying is
that you have so you have continuous
assessment at 16 yeah and you have some
tests as well and then you have a you do
have an exam at 18. you have like a a
baccalaureate and that would have five
or six subjects and a lot of people are
thinking this now it would have a mix of
practical subjects vocational subjects
and academic subjects so at 18 you leave
with a kind of certificate which covers
a whole range of things but also it
covers not just those academic things it
will go into are you good you know sport
music after drama and your character
traits are you resilient are you
determined i mean this is really you
work in a team well you go on about
teams but but
this is this this is really
old-fashioned i'm allowed to say this
because i'm 57. some of the most
intelligent people i know have got
absolutely zero social skills and cannot
have a conversation or or be involved in
any level and i think for me it's about
balance it is about sport is about
public speaking it's about
i don't think we should ban exams in any
which way i think there should be a
degree of practical um you know the
course work but i absolutely say as i
said at the start and you got you both
agree you know we should be preparing
our kids not by saying oh by 16 by the
way we'll have judge when you're any
good or you're not my daughter had
failed maths and english today and she
had every reason by the way with with
dyslexia to fail it but didn't
he'd been on the scrap pete for another
year right and that's that's frightening
so how do we help those kids and also i
keep going on about it i'll give you a
very quick story of a school um
that my son's going to and we wouldn't
see that my son's um you know he's a
reasonable level of education and the
headmaster was telling the story about
this kid and this kid was doing no
goodies and exams and the headmaster we
took time with this boy because he
didn't seem to be switched on at all and
they found out you'd all laugh he liked
skateboarding right so this headmaster
used his brain and gave him i think
three one hours in afternoons during a
week to do skateboarding he now
represents europe for the united kingdom
under 16 and he's passing maths and
english because they found something
practical that galvanized him as a human
being that's the point isn't it it's a
that's the exact point and jeremy what
inspired that boy would have been great
teaching yeah we need great teachers in
our schools that's the key to everything
we get great teachers well i think
whatever they teach them is going to be
successful they are inspiring children
they've got to do that so actually yeah
the teachers may be on strike in a few
months time and i have some sympathy
with them they do deserve more and there
would be more money for them if we got
away from having so many non-teaching
staff in schools
good teachers need to be rewarded
properly they get 19 weeks holiday
though don't they good teachers inspire
kids and they're getting yeah they
inspire cause they are crucial and if
you go look at our system we tend to
recruit from the lower end of the
graduates go to a place like finland
they're recruiting from the top 10
people you can't talk about finland the
prime minister dances with people that
isn't too
final word from you we agree balance
right there must be exams there must be
course work but let's give our kids a
practical education yeah i i agree
balance and there must be exams but we
do not need 30 papers at the age of 16
10 subjects
we've got kids with mental health
problems you know and covered and all
that and
everything else no other european
country does this we are not doing our
kids a service with gcses chris mcgovern
sean griffiths really delighted to see
you both thank you very much indeed for
joining us right next on uncensored the
red arrows are in crisis there's claims
of drunkenness misogyny and assault at
the heart of the raf the big question
for us does the british military have a
culture problem we're coming back in
three plus kick her out or work more
hours that my friends is the dilemma
facing one family who took a ukrainian
refugee i will speak to them live on
this show before 9.
[Music]
do
welcome back to understanding my friends
now royal air force display team the red
arrows are one of the jewels and the
crown of the british military their
colourful patrick of their performances
are the signature of major national
celebrations like the queen's platinum
jubilee in june this year but behind the
pageantry the red arrows are in crisis
facing claims of harassment bullying
drunken balls and treating brawls even
treating female recruits as fresh meat
so just a few bad apples or evidence my
friends that something rotten is at the
heart of the british military joining us
now our former commanding officer of the
british parachute regiment major chip
chapman and former british intelligence
officer philip ingram who is co-founder
of the independent defense authority a
body set up
to advise military personnel if i can
say to both of you welcome and just
start by just listing those red arrows
allegations
female recruits to the raf scams and
base red arrows were considered fresh
meat young recruits were pestered and
bombarded with whatsapp messages as soon
as they joined the squadron drinking
sessions took place just hours before
flights and alcohol fueled fights took
place regularly let me start with chip
chapman is this
uh are these allegations uh
a mirror of a toxic culture in the
british military or is this being over
exaggerated chip
i'd hope they're not but what you can
say is that this is predatory behavior
of the worst sort uh we've been trying
to get rid of this for at least 20 years
i remember going to a focus group in
1999 about letting gay folk into the
military and of course it wasn't the
fact that we're going to let gay folk
into the military whether it's
heterosexual or homosexual people that
are predatory this is just wrong
predatory behavior now the red arrows of
course have team task and individual
that's the three ways that we look at
things they're very good at the team and
toss it's the individuals and the flaws
in their character which is really the
issue here and they needed to be weeded
out
what's really interesting philip if i
could bring you in is that major general
chip chapman just said that 20 years ago
he was part of a focus group to get rid
of this which would
give the impression that these problems
have been obvious to many for many many
years how widespread are these problems
in your opinion
the pro the problems are widespread in
that they exist in all three services
and the issues within the raf red arrows
i know very well indeed and
unfortunately a large number of
allegations um there's a lot of
substance behind them
they're not across the whole of the
services the majority of the armed
services are very good very well behaved
and there's not an issue with them
however the trouble is with these toxic
small pockets that there are
there are failures in command to deal
with the issues that are causing the
toxicity that gets worse and leads into
not just inappropriate behavior but
also verging on criminal behavior
and it's that that undermines the
operational effectiveness of those
particular units i see this as a failure
in command
so this is about leaders chip can i just
say something we were talking about this
in the pre-production meeting and i was
saying that in many services presumably
the military many emergency services
programs i've done there is a gallows
humor and many people in the emergency
services would say we wouldn't get
through our day unless there was galaxy
but there is a massive difference is
there not between gallows humor and
bullying misogyny harassment
and and the military if this is as
widespread as philip says and has been
going on for as long that doesn't that
doesn't shine a great light on us does
it
no it doesn't hurt
any organization should mirror the
culture of its time it's the fact that
cultures change so all the stuff that
was going on 20 40 years ago doesn't
matter what time frame of banter which
would now be deemed to be unacceptable
uh is the modern age when cultures
change we've seen that over the last
hundred years people women didn't have
the vote 100 years ago cultures move on
and it's people sort of the dinosaurs of
the veterans people like me and often
people criticize who are the ones who
are the loudest to shout on this but of
course you had sort of three years ago
this new set of
of recruiting posters for example which
lots of people said woke it wasn't it
really just informs the people who are
out there today generation x generation
zed and they're the people being
recruited so you know the older element
in all the armed forces need to wise off
but about the modern culture and those
that we're recruiting into the army navy
and air force these days there's nothing
wrong with these kids a year ago they
were doing amazing things on that
pitting in afghanistan you um you call
yourself part of the older generation
you say that you know 20 40 years ago
the world was a different place we
accept that but
what would you have done in a different
world if a soldier came to you and said
i'm being bullied there's sexist
behavior i'm being harassed what would
you have done would it be i'm not
criticizing you i'm saying how what
different the world is would you have
said come on stiff upper lip get on with
it or would you have taken those
allegations seriously
i would have brought the sib in straight
away which i did at least two occasions
when i heard those sorts of things there
is no uh nature or way that that stuff
is tolerated there are no shades of grey
in um in discipline there's just
something happens or something doesn't
happen if something happens that's wrong
you deal with it if you don't you've
lost your morality and your leadership
particularly if people don't come to you
in the future you are no longer a leader
if you allow that to be acceptable
phillip you've talked about how you
think there's a problem with the
leadership in the military across the
military what sort of evidence have you
got to back up your claims what are
people coming to you and saying from
across the military spectrum
i've got tons of stories the common
theme across the board is that they
don't trust the chain of command with
their complaints and that's actually
backed up by the previous service
complaints commissioner who turned
around and said in our final evidence to
parliament that ninety percent of those
who should complain don't complain um
because they don't trust the chain of
command um and part of the reason behind
this is what the chin of command does is
it tends to obfuscate it tends to delay
it tends to try and sweep things under
the carpet it tends to try and solve
things in an inappropriate way and bully
complaints in many cases and people get
concerned about that
and therefore a lot of the issues are
sort of either not brought out to the
front um or or they're hidden and that
has a huge effect on it's a relatively
small number of people but it's got a
huge effect on that small number of
people's mental health and their ability
um to operate and it has an effect on
the operational capability of the units
that they're part of i'm very proud of
our military just by the minister of
defense i'm very if i could just say
it's a very proud of them
despite the what austerity and the cuts
have done to them but what's really
interesting is you quite rightly said i
mean i i remember over the years you'd
hear stories of initiation ceremonies at
sandhurst and places like that and kids
not seeing it through the world is a
different place and it's not good or
perhaps right to hear that an
organization would pooh-pooh somebody
saying you know i'm being bullied i'm
being but i'm going to ask the obvious
question that will go down like a lead
balloon i'll start with you and i don't
disrespect anybody would there be part
of the military phillip that would go
come on get on with it stiff upper lip
it's happened for 40 years what you're
moaning about
still
i've already i've i've already
experienced that i've already had people
commenting to me um on social media and
elsewhere saying exactly that and that's
part of the problem your people don't
sit up and listen and deal with it this
is something where it's gone beyond what
would be considered even 20 years ago as
banter or something else it's it's right
into the the very nasty levels of
inappropriate behavior and sir mike
wigston himself before he took over as
chief of the air staff did an
investigation into inappropriate
behaviors in the military and made a
series of recommendations the mod says
they've implemented those
recommendations but it's quite clear in
his own service they haven't well
bearing in mind that the sun reported
last week that one pilot had been
suspended from the red arrows another
resigned due to the toxic culture
tonight uh chip we hear from the mod
this is their statement sexual assault
or harassment has no place in the armed
forces and all allegations are taken
seriously and investigated by the
service police we continue to improve
reporting mechanisms so personnel feel
safe in raising issues and confident
allegations will be acted on
my response very quickly championship is
you know sexual assault or harassment
no talk about misogyny and bullying in
that statement what's your response to
what the mods say tonight chip
well justice delayed is justice denied
i'd like to see swift action in all
those sorts of things we know that all
the armed forces are trying to change
into something where for example
emotional intelligence is something
these days which a leader must have and
all those things that you mentioned
earlier on about stiff upper lip is
against that sort of ethos of the
emotional intelligence which is a facet
of leadership these days but it is those
character flaws that's what really uh
this is about this is not leadership
it's the flaws in attitude behavior and
character those are people we need to
weed out from any aspect of the services
because none of that is acceptable i
guess to finish uh very quickly that the
issue is the world has changed the
military must change as well and i guess
get get themselves away from the belief
that you know if you don't go through
everything and take everything you're
too soft to be a soldier actually that's
not the case the world is different
philly bingham major general chip
chapman thank you very much indeed we
discuss the military and next on
uncensored fighting for her right to
party is the finnish pm's while dancing
a dereliction of duty in these serious
times or is the criticism just a sexist
double standard we'll debate that right
next we're coming right back
[Music]
do
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back my friends now the prime
minister of finland is under increasing
pressure after yet more leaked footage
showed her raunchily parting with
friends samaran's already been forced to
apologize and take a drugs test over the
videos today she told reporters she's
extremely disappointed by the number of
leaks memo to british water companies so
are we and that's not the only thing we
have in common with the finnish prime
minister we know a thing or two about
partying politicians here in the uk bojo
famously turned downing street into a
mullet we wrote this business in the
front parties at the back
but we did think this was a fine
opportunity my friends to look at some
of the other politicians who've
committed murder on the dance floor yes
my friends stand by it's strictly come
dancing or as we call it top of the flop
here we go
right in at number four the original
party prime minister himself up 14 yeah
somebody call the nurse what a complete
idiot at number three climbing four this
week you know him we love him emmanuel
macron's got the clap
not looking remotely uncomfortable
rising four places to number two my
friends our dancing queen that was the
night that bojo resigned and charissa
may look like a right idiot where is she
there look oh
but at number one it's been there 17
weeks the fasting of multicultural
homosexual men thinking about hooking up
in a cheap accommodation
take a breath donald j trump
[Music]
[Applause]
stop
i'm now joined by talk tv presenter mike
graham and political journalist a good
friend ava sentina what did you think
yeah what did you what donald trump what
did you think of my little did you i
thought it was great brilliant yeah it's
great you look completely underwhelmed
uh let's start on a serious note finnish
prime minister i mean
is there double standards uh between men
and women in politics i mean australia's
pm anthony albanese was spotted chugging
down a pint of beer and he was
celebrated yeah but he wouldn't be
celebrated here would he because here
we're terry prairie about all this kind
of stuff except if it's a woman now that
it's a woman all the women in britain
are going isn't it great look at her uh
a fine upstanding vision of femininity
you know if it was a bloke they revealed
everything would all be going that's
disgraceful why is he with his wife
where's her husband where's her husband
is she having some kind of mid-life
crisis that's what all the men are
saying all the men are gawking like kind
of like feral 15 year old staring at her
that's why what that's what the floor is
they are they're obsessed with it i mean
even you know newsrooms up and down this
country can't get enough of her frankly
it's really embarrassing but don't you
think it's more i mean i actually
believe she should be able to party and
have a good time probably not the right
the greatest thing to put out when
you've got a border with probably not
top with russia no no but hang on hang
on the border she has her neighbor okay
putin's out all the time with this top
off singing rape jokes and invading
sovereign nations and for some reason
we're putting all of our anger towards a
woman who's having a dance i don't think
people are angry oh they aren't going to
take a drug
well she actually offered to didn't she
that's because there were people in the
background calling out for some cocaine
i think and that's why she took the drug
test but the other reason that's
interesting is actually but can i can i
make that point without you giving me
looking at me
can you imagine and i know you hate him
right but can you imagine if boris
johnson had had a party right in downing
street where there were topless women
and somebody was shouting out for
cocaine let me tell you that every
single liberal stroke left media outlet
in the land would have said you're a
disgrace and you should be gone so there
is another side too there wasn't any
cocaine
well we don't know that dude well we did
all right i'll give you again
boris johnson serious question with
topless women partying what would you
like you'd always say get him out i
would like to see a video inside the
garrett club or inside the beef state
club and see what all of those toy mps
are in the private members clubs
well then don't ask me the question
about what i like to see boris johnson
because that's possibly if anywhere
that's where you're going to see it are
you telling me off
i have a feeling
yeah i would i would say this right
party away
party away if you want uh
best it came out probably not best it
came out there are some who think that
it's actually a russian plot to get rid
of her because uh you know they don't
like her very much and she wants to join
nato and all of that so they could be
hacking into somebody's icloud possibly
um but it's a bit unwise to let all of
that stuff be impeccable youth may be
the youngest leader in the world yeah
she's not that young though she's 36.
that's very young but you know it is for
mike and i yes young well it's young but
it's not young
let's move on that i actually i'm going
to state my my my not my career because
i've got one i'm gonna i'm gonna stake
uh what i believe on the next thing
there is a story this week that i hope
we all find absolutely disgusting a town
at the center of one of britain's most
notorious child sex scandals rotherham
asian grooming gangs we all know about
this has been named as the world's first
children's capital of culture over i
mean what what what do you say to that i
mean what do you say to that it's just
it's just the only thing the only
slightly good thing about this being in
the press is that maybe we can have a
re-examine about the fact that since
that whole scandal was broken
barely any funding has gone into social
housing really any funding has gone into
social homes and or rectifying the issue
of preventing a future problem i mean
i've spoken
about this this week and she was
obviously one of those campaigners who
managed to get something done about all
the horrible stuff and she was
absolutely amazed that anyone would
think that this will somehow rejuvenate
the the the area and it will somehow
make people think of rotherham in a
different way it's just bizarre i don't
think rotherham will be looked at in any
different way until they deal with this
and they haven't dealt with and there
are still cases coming up all the time
but i i mean without without wanting to
sound like you're you're your loved
child
what idiot went oh i'll tell you what
the children's the bet you know the
children's capital of culture now let's
pick could be any any city in the world
let's pick rotherham that just doesn't
make sense it's probably the same idiot
that doesn't allocate the correct
funding where it should go completely
agree um
we were all quite rightly the world has
been shocked the united kingdom in shock
about olivia pratt corbell's senseless
murder on monday night um in terms of
where we're at there's a new statement
from the family tonight because it's a
big thing
that the man that was chased into the
house won't open up and it's all about
will the criminal underworld and
liverpool you know say anything to find
this man others say he's already gone
the family have just released a
statement saying liv was adored by
everyone who knew her and would
instantly make friends with anyone and
everyone she was often seen going up and
down the street on a new bike she just
got for her birthday or her life was
short her personality certainly wasn't
and she lived it the most she could and
would blow people away with a wit and
kindness we as a family are heartbroken
and have lost a huge part of our lives
and if anyone knows anything now is the
time to speak up it's not about being a
snitch or a grass it's about finding out
who took our baby away please do the
right thing mike it's just heartbreaking
isn't it i mean you look at those
pictures and you know we've got children
you know i remember i remember when it
happened i just remembered my daughter
who you know um when she was nine years
old i mean it's just it's just
awful you can't even begin to think you
know what i was thinking today the
people who are going to spend this
weekend ordering cocaine middle class
people that make quite a lot of money
they should think about where that's
coming from because it's coming from
there and that's what they're doing and
that's what they're funding and that's
what they're actually you know helping
to make sure that it continues to be
like that ava you might you might um
actually agree with me i i look i look
sometimes at this country
country i'm very proud of and i'm
becoming increasingly unproud of it i
look at lawlessness i look at gang
culture knives guns i look at the social
problems we've got how do we how do we
deal with this i think that we're
probably getting a bit excited there as
much as i agree with you
but
this has always been endemic it's just
that we now we're now talking about it a
lot more and liverpool has had this
issue for years for decades and then the
second that it comes into the media
spotlight suddenly they're now
allocating more money for bobbies to go
on to the b for police cars to be sent
around the city there's been a gun
problem for years in liverpool and it's
shocking that no one's no one's bothered
to deal with it but the trouble is now
because of the way that the gun crime uh
is fueled by the drug business the drug
business is now so big you know somebody
once said to me if you take out a county
line or you take out a drug baron within
five minutes there's another one well i
mean they they they get something like
one-eighth of all the drugs that come
into this country they confiscate but
there's loads more coming in there's
loads more people doing it britain is
now the cocaine capital of europe you
know it's ridiculous i just hope i i
just thought that that actually somebody
does open their mouth because that kid
does they really showed this and also
the other thing that you're right how
awful the the guy who was was shot um
was taken to hospital by his mate yeah
who left the little girl there didn't
take her and the one that's in hospital
won't speak and he won't speak i mean
what a pair of scumbags i'm not allowed
to say on television what i think but
yeah good luck um stephen barkley on a
lighter note if you've seen this kid
just watch this brilliant this is the
health section being ambushed by could
be a labor activist or just an angry
pensioner have a look
uh that plan for jobs has protected are
you gonna do anything about the
ambulances waiting and the people dying
out well don't you think 12 years is
long enough
yes and we are well
you've done bugger all about it people
have died and all you've done is nothing
he's disgraceful look at the way he
looks at her like she's a constituent
she votes him in she pays his wages and
that's the way that he looks at her that
they don't care they don't care at all
and they keep saying as well well he was
he was about to make that statement
wasn't he well we are building 20 new
hospitals and you know we are actually
getting the waiting list down no they're
not they're actually not they're not
right you saw they are doing nothing you
saw the picture on the front of the
mirror last week that i'll never forgive
you forget that the guy with an awning
over his body for 16 hours i feel do you
know apart from the patients i feel
sorry for the people who work in
ambulance control centers imagine this
i've got four ambulances and 70 people
do i go to the granny who's broken a leg
because on the floor do i go the kid
who's been in a car crash or somebody's
been knifed i don't understand why we
can't i mean don't start me with nhs
because we need to stop pouring money
down to brainstorming sessions and spend
it on things that matter but it's just
just appalling and and this woman who
perhaps in the past would be seen as
some sort of labor weirdo is speaking
what most people in this country feel
now
it's always true isn't it that one
incident kind of sums everything up and
that's it you know it's her saying
you've done you know i don't know if i
can say it might have to say bugger all
you've done they have done bugger all
they've been doing bugger rule since
about three months ago but they've been
doing a lot of deflection as well i mean
12 years in power and somehow it's still
not their fault that waiting times are
this long it's it's shocking it is
absolutely shocking uh you are my
favorite duo um thank you you obviously
prepared brilliantly yes i
graham 10 o'clock tomorrow morning on
talk uh breakfast before that with me
ava thank you very much indeed thank you
both of you we'll see you next week
right next on uncensored on the eve of
another energy price hike can public
support for ukraine survive the economic
crisis will speak to a family who took
in a refugee but can no longer afford to
keep them we're coming back in three
[Music]
welcome back my friends now tomorrow
morning at 7 a.m off gem will announce
another hike in the energy price cap
signaling more bad news for hard-up
families few prices have rocketed around
the world in part because of that war in
ukraine but as brits pay higher bills
prime minister boris johnson wants us to
remember that the ukrainians are paying
in blood
tonight and sense we want to know can
the public support for this war survive
the economic crisis and should those
taking in ukrainian refugees be getting
more than 350 quid a month joining me
now from east london is admiral lord
west who thinks we must continue to
confront russia and it's a small price
to pay in wales we have oliver orchard
who's taken in a ukrainian refugee but
is struggling by his own admission to
pay the bills in the studio is heritage
party leader david curtin who says that
britain should be putting the british
people first um i'd like to go to oliver
in wales if i can um really as a
starting point oliver you and your
family made that decision in may
uh you say that you have received your
350 pounds per month in lieu but the
reality for you now
is it's a struggle financially
well i i suppose i should actually sort
of preface this and say that you know
it's not that much of a struggle as it
stands um
we are in a position where
we can do this we believe in the
principle of what we're doing we stand
by it
everybody is feeling the pinch
and we are making our way through this
and it will be absolutely fine so we are
not struggling
but what i will say is on that note
the early days of this
when she first arrived
and
we had to
sort out
everything um from food and utilities
and
uh making sure she was finding work and
all those other bits
that's when we felt the pinch initially
and i think that's where a lot of people
may have struggled in that but you
staged the eight to ten weeks oliver you
told my team because we built up such a
relationship with her we don't want her
to leave in a difficult situation but
we're finding ourselves increasing the
financial situation either she has to go
or we have to work extra hours so that
is an issue isn't it
it's something it's an it's an issue but
there are bigger issues than that you're
a good person you can only
well no i
you know we discussed this with your
team and
uh the way i see it yes i haven't i have
worked a lot more days and more hours
i'm still feeling the echo and
the echo of dunkirk spirit my i think of
my great grandfather at times like this
he was a captain in world war ii
and
it's instinctive
i don't have a problem it's okay if i've
saved one person and i saved her son
yeah from
being injured wounded on the front line
um then we've done our part it's okay um
let's bring in um if i can david curtin
um heritage party leader you say about
boris who said yesterday you know we're
struggling but your bills that are
increasing you know they're paying in
blood i do wonder i mean i i find myself
in a difficult position because i
absolutely know that ukrainian war is
not just about ukraine it's about europe
but i also always it's like the
immigration issue and nobody talked
about it for years the british people
are really struggling right now and the
british people i don't know whether it's
called war fatigue or whatever i worry
not only the ones that have taken people
ukrainians in and shown their nice side
but that could be a struggle but people
are struggling to survive and they will
look at 54 million yesterday no
disrespect to ukraine will they not and
go
we can't power bills and that's on the
top of a billion or so that's already
been given to the ukrainian government
in weapons and money i think boris there
is making this statement because he
sound wants to sound like church and
he's got this great idea that he's going
to be seen in history as a churchill
like figure but he's not putting the
british people first and he is not going
to suffer from this he's not going to
struggle because he has a very very
large mp salary even when he steps down
as prime minister he'll still get a lot
of money coming in and he's completely
out of touch with ordinary british
people who are suffering a quarter of
british families taking part in the
homes for ukraine scheme is set to quit
in the coming weeks citing lack of
support amid soaring inflation energy
bills with the greatest respect to me
man uh oliver in in in in wales you can
tell he's a thoroughly decent man but he
did say at the end yes i don't regret
doing it but i'm having to work extra
hours it is becoming more difficult for
people tomorrow that off-gem
announcement at 7am could say 6 000
pounds i'm terrified that families will
go to the wall aren't you absolutely i
mean oliver there obviously did it from
the goodness of his heart
of reasons i mean i i think we should
sit down actually you know on a wider
sense and try to end the conflict so
that we don't need uh you know to take
more refugees that's another kind of
issue i mean it is another question i'd
like to bring an admiral lord west uh
former first sea lord you say admiral
west uh boris is right we have to
confront russia and ukraine i might
agree with that as well but i want to
ask you this
in doing that are we causing our own
people to suffer unnecessarily
um i think there are a whole
raft of things that are making a perfect
storm in terms of uh people's incomes
and the the amount of money they have to
spend but i have no doubt whatsoever
that
making sure we support ukraine is
putting the british people first we have
in putin a man who used polonium a
radioactive very unpleasant material
quite freely in london to kill someone
we know he then used a nerve agent to
kill people kill someone in salisbury he
breaks all all of the accepted norms of
behavior he has made it very clear that
he wants to see russia back to where it
was when it was a soviet union and i'm
afraid we had to confront him now i'm
afraid that is costing money and it's
difficult i think boris is correct that
actually ukraine are paying in terms of
blood um and and that's not very nice
but if we don't stop him we will end up
being a position where our people are
paying in but the point is
weirdly
i agree with that but as david curtin
says and and and oliver alluded to david
i wonder whether politicians actually
truly understand because they've had six
weeks holiday and we've had a you know
we've had a government that's not been
there do they know what tomorrow morning
means to so many families the length and
breadth of this country first of all i'd
say i do actually disagree with admiral
lord west i think we should have
shouldn't have got into the conflict in
the first place and we should be
de-escalating the conflict rather than
trying to prolong it because that is
actually does he want to de-escalate it
vladimir putin if you don't take on
somebody like that as lord west says
what do you get is he gonna run over
everywhere else if you sit around the
table and negotiate and stick to the
minsk agreements which we had in place
but he didn't agree with them he's been
smarting since the youth soviet union
union was split up and he's gone into a
sovereign independent nation or not at
all i think if you look at the wider
issue that the russian ethnic russian
people in the donbass area were being
shelled and maimed and killed for eight
years and they've gone in to protect
them so that's a difference i don't
agree with that but we've all got
opinions lord west you wanted to jump in
i haven't got much time sorry i i
totally disagree with that
why
i've seen i've lost something there oh
he's gone
he disagrees with me he disagrees i mean
that that is the fact i mean if we'd
stuck to the minsk agreement well i
disagree with that yeah okay i disagree
with that
okay
we may have to disagree on that but i
think nate coming back to you know how
this is impacting on british families
that's what we need to put first and we
need to actually try to alleviate the
suffering and the cost of living the
cost of energy crisis i agree which is
coming tomorrow morning let's just talk
oliver very quickly back to wales you
are the person that took in a family
you're such a good man i've got 30
seconds you're not going to say you
regret it but as things get tougher as
that off gem announcement happens
tomorrow what happens if you can't make
ends meet what goes first your family or
the ukrainian lady 30 seconds go
no no we'll always find a way to protect
her i minimize the windows on the
desktop on this one back down to just
human stories she's been for a lot her
son has been for a lot i still believe
if we just do right by another ukrainian
person we can end the war that way it's
it's human stories for me anyway thank
you very much indeed oliver let's finish
with admiral lord west whose sound is
back you were very vocal you said i
disagree 30 seconds sir
yeah i disagree entirely that we mustn't
confront putin when it comes to spending
money i'm afraid when you're faced with
a possibility of war that is where
you've got to spend your money if putin
succeeds and if we then went to a a
greater war then the nhs welfare these
things would mean absolutely nothing
because it's the destruction end of your
country and your civilization very quick
final question do you think the british
people have the stomach to suffer as
they are
and keep supporting this war admiral
lord west
yes or no
i think the british people have yes
except they do want to know that the
people ruling them understand the pain
that is being caused by a whole series
of other things thank you very much
indeed and david that's the point where
is the damn government nobody's
explaining anything to us 20 seconds
yeah well the governor boris johnson's
on holiday and he's uh gallivanting off
to kiev he's he's doing public
relationships doing public relations for
himself but he's not understanding what
people are going through and that is the
key thing that he should be attending to
thank you very much dude oliver in wales
debbie curtin the studio admiral lord
west tomorrow morning off gem 7 a.m they
say bills could be upwards of six and a
half grand what will that mean we're on
breakfast on talk from 6 30 but that my
friends is it from me tonight i'm on
censor back tomorrow night from eight
whatever you're up to he told me to say
it make sure you keep it uncensored have
a great thursday
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers alan in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the big step this simply does not wash
look who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams olivia
pratt corbell's family have released a
statement asking who took our baby away
from us police in liverpool say they
won't rest until they find the
nine-year-old's killer who's still at
large urging people to come forward with
information olivia's family said that
although her life was short her
personality wasn't
gcse results show a stark divide between
the southeast and the rest of england
analysis shows that around a third of
students in london achieve top grades
compared to a quarter or less in other
regions
and the country can expect more train
strikes after drivers at three companies
voted overwhelmingly to walk out in a
dispute over pay those from chilton
northern and transparent express backed
industrial action
that's all for now we'll have more news
updates after the talk
[Music]
i